[Musique]
défendre l'idée européenne ce n'est pas
défendre une idée abstraite la dilution
en quelque sorte de nos propres
souveraineté non c'est acté du fait que
face à ces grands bouleversements du
monde ces grandes transformations ce
moment que nous vivons nous avons besoin
d'une souveraineté plus forte que la
nôtre complémentaires et pas de
substitution
le président de la république ce sera
donc adressé pendant près de trois
heures aux parlementaires européens il a
réaffirmé
durant cet échange parfois musclées avec
les députés sa vision de l'europe de
demain alors près d'un an après son
élection à la présidence de la ve
république
retour sur ce qu'il a proposé ces 70
propositions autour de l'union
européenne at il réussi quel est son
bilan on en débat avec mes invités mais
d'abord retour arrière sur cette année
européenne
[Musique]
il a fait de l'europe le squelette de sa
campagne présidentielle une europe
positive dans laquelle la france doit
assumer son leadership
porté par deux tiers des français face à
marine le pen emmanuel macron a très
vite repris son bâton de maréchal
quelques jours après les élections
législatives en allemagne il prend la
parole à la sorbonne objectif dessiner
les contours de l'europe de demain et
peser sur les négociations de coalition
à berlin l'europe que nous connaissons
est trop faible trop lente trop
inefficace mais l'europe seule peut nous
donner une capacité d'action dans le
monde face aux grands défis
contemporains dans un discours enflammé
de plus d'une heure et demie le
président de la république propose tous
azimuts défense économie zone euro
fiscalité éducation migration
convergence fiscale et sociale est
toujours sa ligne l'europe qui protège
quitte à être à plusieurs vitesses
depuis c'est peu dire que la plupart des
perspectives tracées par emmanuel macron
suscite des résistances dans la capitale
tous louent le leadership retrouver de
paris ne près d'un an après son élection
c'est la fin de l'état de grâce européen
si la france a remporté des avancées
symbolique sur le travail détachées ou
la taxation des gaffes à les
négociations sur une réforme de la
politique migratoire ou sur
l'approfondissement de la zone euro
patine et pour cause
l'allemagne englué dans ces négociations
a accouché d'un accord de coalition en
mars six mois après des législatives qui
ont profondément affaibli la chancelière
angela merkel et depuis c'est l'italie
qui est plongé dans une impasse
politique
un front des pays du nord de l'europe
s'est formée et tient tête également à
paris ces libéraux peu prompts à réguler
et créer des dispositifs de solidarité
entre les vingt-sept ne veulent pas
entendre parler d'un budget de la zone
euro mais face au réel et à l' isolement
le président de la république garde le
cap
la chancelière l'a dit notre objectif
c'est de pouvoir converger au mois de
mars
parce qu'à ce moment là une étape
politique sera passée en allemagne et
nous aurons une capacité à construire
ensemble beaucoup plus clairement sur ce
sujet des propositions franco allemandes
doivent aboutir dans les prochaines
semaines et sauront menu du conseil
européen de juin
un test pour l'elysée à quelques mois
des élections européennes
alors près d'un an après l'arrivée au
pouvoir des manuels macro que dire de ce
bilan au niveau européen j'ai le plaisir
donc de recevoir andré ashfaq bonjour
vous êtes député européen allemand
membre du groupe ppe c'est à dire la cd
ou cs ou en allemagne bienvenue à vous
en face de vous guillaume balas vous
êtes français vous êtes socialistes
démocrates et vous avez donc quitté le
parti socialiste il ya quelques mois
pour rejoindre génération le mouvement
de benoît hamon
bienvenue à vous et enfin clémentine
forissier vous êtes rédactrice en chef
du site contexte un site dédié au
c'est aux affaires politiques françaises
et européennes bien entendu alors
peut-être quelques mots sur parce qu'on
vient d'entendre
on se souvient tous du discours de la
seconde on se souvient à quel point le
président de la république avait fait de
l'europe donc le squelette de sa
campagne présidentielle au nom après
andrea schopp qu'est ce que vous auriez
à dire de ce bilan européen du président
de la république française je trouve ça
serait difficile de faire un bilan
d'abord résidents de 28 chefs d'état wen
hui il a eu ses idées qu'il a décrit
clairement à la sorbonne il les a repris
hier au parlement européen ouais je
trouvais il ya de bons arguments de pour
beaucoup de points qu'il propose 70
propositions je trouvais beaucoup de ces
points sont très positifs mais pour
l'instant on n'a pas encore eu la
majorité mais c'est pas sa faute à lui
c'est une faute dans collective
c'est une faute dans les structures
européennes dans les élections
nationales et comme ça donc il faut
maintenant essayer de boucler tout ça
laisse un grand allemand karl marx
disait alors qu'il savait que ça allait
vous plaire que le plus difficile c'est
de montrer le réel et je pense que nous
sommes rentrés sur la question
européenne en france depuis vingt ans et
on pouvait penser que ça allait être
rompu avec emmanuel macron et en fait ça
continue dans l'illusion c'est à dire
que la parole les mots le discours
doivent compenser en fait le défaut de
stratégie
qu'est ce qui s'est passé emmanuel
macron avait l'occasion de rompre avec
la stratégie de nicolas sarkozy de
jacques chirac
précédemment et de françois hollande si
on peut dire qu'il ya une stratégie qui
était en gros de juste après l'élection
présidentielle vous savez ce voyage à
berlin
oui hein qui
à vocation à créer le choc de confiance
pour le reste de l'europe et la
symbolisation comme il ya un défaut
d'analysé en france sur ce qui se passe
en europe du nord en allemagne sur
comment les sociétés de ces pays sont
aujourd'hui extrêmement inquiètes sur un
certain nombre de sujets ils ne voient
pas qu'en fait il n'y a pas de nous il
n'y a pas de possibilité et qu'on ne
peut plus discuter en europe de cette
manière là c'est pour ça qu'il faut
sortir du couple est toujours arrivé à
la fin au couple franco-allemand ouais
mais regardez il n'a qu'a lancé hier
plus personne ne supporte cette idée qui
aura un période franco-allemand qui
décide pour la était effectivement
beaucoup
d'abord ouvrir la discussion et je pense
que en réalité
macron a perdu un an et il a perdu un an
parce qu'il n'a pas vu qu'il y avait
d'autres pays avec les cagoules et
discuter et notamment nous avons laissé
l'italie dérivés dans une crise
notamment à cause de crise migratoire où
la france a été odieuse dans son
comportement par rapport à l'italie et
qui fait qu'aujourd'hui et bien l'italie
est irrattrapable pour longtemps et donc
je pense qu'en fait ça va être très
difficile pour tous les projets d'
emmanuel macron je pense que du coup il
va falloir faire de la politique du
symbole c'est les gaffes à ces
entourloupes sur le travail des tâches
et où il nous a inventé
comment dire un accord pour lequel il
n'est pour rien et le seul point sur
lequel il a contribué est en fait les
douze mois notamment de passer de 24 à
douze mois pour le travail des tâches et
ne sert à rien et surtout l effet besoin
de textes randonnée ou les transports
non mais je dis c'est important parce
que finalement la loire seul acte qu'il
a eue en étant en soi une entourloupe
donc attention parce que si la france
c'est simplement des symboles on va
échouer très largement clémentine
forissier ce que vous diriez que le
président de la république a eu une
politique de symbole depuis un an ou est
ce qu'il a été aussi comme le dit
andreas schwab empêcher du fait d'une
politique en fait qui doit
nécessairement se faire avant de suite
moi je pense que j'aurai une position
peut être entré deux mois je sais pas là
pour exprimer une position est ce qu'on
peut quand même simplement observer
c'est que il a juste après son élection
est en effet été voir un gala merkel qui
elle même était en perde élection donc
dans une situation assez complexe
après il ya eu une sorte de période de
glaciation en allemagne
ça a duré six mois qui a pris beaucoup
plus de temps que prévu effectivement
comme vous le disais dans votre sujet un
gala merkel il a sorti affaibli parce
que la coalition qui est fort mais là en
fait on voit bien la difficulté qu'elle
pourrait avoir à porter ou à soutenir
des projets des manières mâcon sur la
réforme de la zone euro notamment
donc c'est intéressant et sur l'italie
effectivement alors je pas que ce fait
d'accord avec vous sur un point c'est
que émaillera quand il a quand même
soutenu plus ou moins matteo renzi le
parti démocrate il ya eu des signaux qui
ont été envoyés à ces améliorations mais
en fait les blancs quoi papa sûr pas sur
ce sujet mais en fait le problème c'est
que c'est que l'italie était dans une
situation déjà ou politique bien plus
compliqué ça j'ai pas tout à fait
d'accord avec votre analyse sur le
couple franco allemand c'est vrai que ça
lui était reproché mais si on se replace
dans lé quinquennat précédent nicolas
sarkozy françois hollande
tous les deux ils sont certes allé voir
angela merkel très vite après leur
élection mais ils ont tous les deux misé
au départ aussi sur les autres pays et
ils sont revenus après à l'allemagne en
dire en fait on peut pas faire comme si
on pouvait se débrouiller sans
l'allemagne donc je pige pas tout à fait
d'accord pour dire que c'est que
personne n'est d'accord alors peut-être
andré alphabet ensuite justement vais
retourner dans l'hémicycle écoute
emmanuel macron parce qu'il a eu des
mots assez durs là dessus oui alors
aussi jeu si vous permettez je tousse
crache pas cette analyse
c'est pas un débat ici à l'europe hebdo
sur la france alors on part sur l'europe
il faut que je vous dise que c'est pas
macron qui peut décider lui même ce bien
sûr mais on a cette impression avec vous
c'est pas lui qui disent le gong
il est un président de 28 il a ses idées
et j'admire ces idées mais maintenant et
la politique c'est le long terme
maintenant il faut trouver des majorités
pour y arriver bien sûr travail pour y
arriver mais on peut pas masquer il a
été chargé des mails jamais travaillé
oui mais on est à chavez qu'il a été
chercher des majorités ou est-ce qu'il a
justement trop attendu que
l'allemagne ça va être extrêmement
difficile vous avez des élections en
italie il à bout les aider à l'italie
mais si rainsy a perdu c'est pas sa
faute il a voulu avec merkel avancer si
nous avons perdu des votes c'est pas la
faute aux maquereaux et dans d autres
pays aussi c'est difficile pour vous
c'est l'europe et c'est ça rend
difficile toute cette idée de
d'améliorer le 7 un contexte assez
patent qu'il l'a voulu mais c'est qu'il
a été empêché par un contexte alors
justement retour dans l'hémicycle donc
emmanuel macron s'est adressé pendant
plus de trois heures il ya eu un échange
assez long avec les députés européens
ici dans l'hémicycle retour sur un
moment qui fera certainement beaucoup
parlé on écoute moi je ne veux pas
appartenir à une génération de
somnambule je ne veux pas appartenir à
une génération qui aura oublié son
propre passé ou qui refusera de voir les
tourments de son propre présent chacun
dans les temps qui s'ouvre prendra ses
responsabilités mais je veux appartenir
à une génération qui aura décidé
fermement de défendre sa démocratie
parce que ça n'est pas un mot qui ne
sale plus auquel on s'est habitués ou
dans lequel on s'étale en dit c'est un
mot qui a tout son sens parce qu'il est
le fruit de batailles passées je veux
appartenir à une génération qui défendra
cette souveraineté européenne parce que
nous nous sommes battus pour l'avoir
parce qu'elle a un sens et parce qu'elle
est la condition qui permettra aux
générations à venir de choisir à ce
moment là elles mêmes leur avenir et je
ne cèderai aucune fascination pour les
souverainetés autoritaire je ne céderait
à aucune facilité des temps présents
mais je pense qu'ensemble notre
responsabilité dans les mois à venir
c'est d'organiser le vrai débat européen
d'avoir les véritables échéances
européennes qui seules permettront à nos
peuples de choisir ce qu'ils veulent une
europe qui ne proposent plus ceux qui
veulent une europe du repli ceux qui
veulent une europe de l' habitude ou
ceux qui sont prêt à porter une europe
de l'ambition d'une souveraineté
réinventer d'une démocratie vivante
celle à laquelle nous croyons andreas
fab
quand on entend emmanuel macron parler
de l'europe d habitude on n'a pas pu
s'empêcher de penser angela merkel et à
la de céder ou cs ou votre parti qui
potentiellement tirer un petit peu cette
volonté de réforme vers le bas alors
comment est ce que vous avez pris ce
moment alors je ne surtout pas penser à
léa les milliers de membres du cdu il ya
beaucoup d'opinions là dedans j'ai
beaucoup admiré la façon comment macron
à aborder les choses et je trouve qu'il
faut dire qu'il a rompu avec un point
qui a toujours posé problème entre la
france l'allemagne c'est la souveraineté
nationale de mon point de vue l'huile
est le premier à dire la souveraineté
nationale ne joue plus un rôle comme
dans le passé car la seule chance que
nous avons c'est une souveraineté
européenne et c'était toujours le point
de vue de l'allemagne nous avons dit on
peut partager plus si on partage aussi
la souveraineté donc je pense qu'il a
vraiment organiser une idée qui peut
nous lis beaucoup plus facilement que
dans le passé sur l'idée de souveraineté
mais je reviens donc à ma question
initiale est ce que sur l'idée d'europe
d habitude il n'y avait pas aussi un
signal clair envoyé à berlin dans l'idée
de faire aussi un peu bouger les choses
il faut il faut dire que lui l'a rompu
avec les habitudes avec 7
avec ce changement c'est vrai que dans
d'autres pays c'est plus difficile bs
oui la question de la souveraineté
européenne s'est défendue depuis
longtemps en fait
emmanuel mâcon reprend j'ai à dire un
patrimoine des discussions française sur
l'europe aujourd'hui pour faire un
ensemble de propositions qui sont celles
que par exemple les socialistes font
depuis depuis très longtemps le problème
qu'il y a et c'est ça moi qui me gêne
beaucoup dans ce discours là c'est
encore une fois l'illusion et la réalité
et l'illusion elle est dans le fait de
penser qu' aujourd'hui en europe
les deux camps qui vont s'affronter
c'est d'un côté le camp nationaliste et
nico autoritaire or ban et de l'autre
côté mais gentils démocrates ça pour moi
c'est la dépolitisation absolue de tous
les sujets parce que le vrai clivage
pour moi il n'est pas là le vrai clivage
il est pas de savoir si il faut rompre
avec la démocratie
une grande majorité des gens ne veulent
pas rompre avec la démocratie mais c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait la grande
majorité des tables
aujourd'hui en europe je aujourd'hui en
europe que les gens sont attachés à
démocratie et qu'il faut la défendre
mais il faut qu'elle soit utile qu'est
ce qu'on fait sur les grands sujets
aujourd'hui je pense notamment à
l'écologie je les ai eu sur le sujet
évité par tout le monde c'est à dire on
n'en parle jamais on n'a quasiment pas
parlé d'ailleurs hier d'ailleurs
président à un public on n'a même pas
parlé dans la longue interview qu'il a
qui l'a fait récemment le sujet est
absolument centrale
on voit que nous sommes dans une
situation catastrophique aujourd'hui
qu'est ce qu'on fait en europe
je vais le dire très honnêtement pas
grand chose à partir de là quel est le
grand projet européen accompagnée des
moyens financiers du budget peut le
faire pardon mais il ya quand même des
lots en cause est le problème il est là
on sait que sur ces sujets y aura des
clivages sur le sujet de la lutte contre
le dumping social
il y aura des clivages parce
qu'aujourd'hui un certain nombre de gens
qui soutiennent emmanuel macron me font
bien rire quand j'entends que
aujourd'hui veulent une europe sociale
c'est eux qui la combattent pied à pied
ici constamment et qui refuse toutes les
avancées sociales donc sérieusement les
libéraux on est dans le doute la ville
mais alors clément d'une forissier là
j'entends ce que vous dites mais las
mais est-ce que du coup ce discours
qu'il a fait aux tours justement des
valeurs européennes de faire attention
justement à ne pas se laisser grignoter
par ces démocraties libérales au recul
du droit au repli des droits
fondamentaux
est ce que ce n'est pas aussi un moyen
de passer outre sur justement le manque
d'avancées sur les réformes qu'il
apportait il y a plusieurs mois et qui
pour le coup en fait pour l'instant sont
un peu au point mort en fait je pense y
avait deux choses
hier il y avait c'était une sorte de
slogan il y avait d'un côté la
souveraineté européenne de l'autre côté
la lutte contre les démocraties
libérales
il y avait ces deux ces deux aspects qui
faisait un peu slogan d'élections en
fait on aurait pu se dire maintien c'est
ça qui va être au meilleur de la
campagne et tous a englobé dans le
lancement de campagne électorale il y
avait un petit air comme ça alors je
sais moi c'est un bois du personnel il y
avait un petit air de lancement campagne
ce qui est intéressant c'est de voir si
dans les mois qui viennent il ya quand
même deux gros sujets trois mêmes qui
vont être sur la table c'est le budget
les le début des négociations sur le
budget de l'ue eux et avec quand même
des éléments qui ont été soulignés c'est
à dire il dit par exemple sur la
politique régionale il faut que ce soit
conditionné
des critères de critères de convergence
sociaux et j'ai pu caler le fiscaux et
sociaux
donc c'est intéressant de voir est ce
que ça c'est des mots qu'ils utilisent
effectivement est ce qu'après derrière
il va y avoir un rapport de force qui va
se créer un rapport de force politique
pour réussir à faire passer ces
choses-là d'icade une conditionnalité
ça voudrait dire que quoi la pologne la
hongrie parce qu'elle ne respecte pas
l'état de droit et les valeurs
européennes se verrait couper des
budgets par exemple la réforme
déjà c'est intéressant incroyable
finalement ce qu'il dit est ce qu'il dit
à l'allemagne en creux c'est il faut de
la solidarité etc ça en fait derrière
cette histoire de budget de la zone euro
c'est c'est une forme de solidarité
européenne qu'ils ont et je dirais de
mettre en place par rapport aux règles
un peu contraignantes
enfin même très contraignantes qui
aurait été qu'ils existent jusqu'à
présent et la question c'est comment
va-t-il réussir à faire en sorte que ces
propositions françaises là ce qu'il
soutient il est quand même c'est une
certaine forme de capital politique
engagée là dessus comment at il réussi à
aller au delà des mots et ça c'est un
cétacé pas simple et franchement c'est
vrai que on peut se demander si à un
moment il faudra pas taper très fort du
poing sur la table et d'un bep très fort
du poing sur la table ça veut dire quoi
est ce que ça veut dire je sais pas
alors là à quitter la table était la
table à quel moment
oui le rapport de force votre petit pois
a créé pour qu'on aille au delà des mots
andrea cheveux parce qu'il va falloir
créer ce rapport de force pour faire une
chèvre accord politique de la chaise
vide
oui et je ne vois pas le choix je n'en
sais rien je pose la caisse je ne vois
pas le troisième point que vous avez
raté de dire le troisième point la
migration est donc soit ils ont gagné
ensemble
oui surtout de la femme voit ensemble on
est d'accord sur beaucoup de points par
exemple sur frontex comment organiser
des frontières extérieures plus sûr plus
sécurisé on est d'accord entre la france
la même année sur le tout point sur le
budget on est d'accord entre la france
et l'allemagne et pas vraiment
absolument il a promis hier qu'il va
contribuer plus moi m'ont dit qu'ils
vont aussi contribuer plus c'est le
détail l'agriculture en france est plus
important qu'en allemagne on a encore
des plus des questions résoudrait on
peut pas seulement faire des belles
phrases il faut maintenant travailler
mais on est d'accord là dessus
la seule partie où il ya des thèmes très
nationale c'est pas le nationalisme mais
les allemands sont un peu durs par
tradition par l'histoire sur les pas
épargner de l'argent français sont
plus généreux mais en fait les gens dans
la rue ils ont les mêmes sentiments en
france et en allemagne c'est plutôt le
débat national qui est un peu différent
et c'est vrai que sur ce point ça sera
plus difficile de notre point de vue
tous les états membres de la de l'union
européenne ont vocation une certaine
obligation à un moment donné de rentrer
dans l'eurozone
donc pour notre de notre point de vue ça
fait pas beaucoup de sens de créer un
budget spécial pour ceux qui l'ont déjà
dedans il faut y a que tout le monde y
aille
et en plus avec le président on manque
déjà de l'argent donc on voit pas où on
peut encore intégré l'idée de macron de
faire encore un buteur et le rejoindre
est ce que andré h fab donc emmanuel
macron et et la chancelière vont
discuter de tout ça est ce que l'idée
c'est au sida d'entrer dans une
négociation sur à la fois les questions
de migration sur les questions de zone
euro puisqu'il ya une feuille de route
qui doit être présenté rapidement avant
le conseil européen de juin en
franco-allemand justement est ce qu'il
ya une possibilité de négociations un
peu marchands de tapis entre guillemets
ou je te donne un peu sur la zone euro
et tu me donnes un peu sur les
migrations
est-ce que ça c'est quelque chose qui
peut je suis convaincu qu eux mêmes la
crau et angela merkel vont parler
sérieusement de coin des points car tous
les points sont justifiées mais c'est
vrai qu'en politique on peut à peut pas
avancer toutes au même moment vers 6h
faut faire papa repas et ils vont
essayer de faire une fouille feuille de
route qui convient à la mais en même
temps à maquereau et à merkel et m balès
pas du tout croyez pas je pense qu'il y
aura peut-être des petites avancées mais
je pense qu'il n'y aura rien de
substantiel et pour des raisons
extrêmement profonde de divergence
aujourd'hui qu'ils ne sont pas des
divergences d'idées de chefs d'état qui
sont des divergences profondes en termes
économiques sociales idéologiques
culturelles notamment entre l'allemagne
mais pas que l'allemagne toute la zone
nord de l'europe aujourd'hui et la
france si nous avons pour objectif
vraiment de créer de la solidarité
européenne de créer les moyens
économiques notamment de transformer nos
économies d'un point de vue écologique
de faire enfin de l'harmonisation au
moins de la convergence sociale
je suis assez convaincu aujourd'hui que
ça ne passera pas par l'europe des
gouvernements
je ne crois pas à la capacité de
l'europe intergouvernementale
aujourd'hui alors là ça veut dire que
vous irez sont gérables
et donc bon mais si vous laissez c'est
le pathos échec si vous me dites ça je
vous dis mais vous y croyez franchement
l europe à 28,27 bientôt où ils sont
capables de se mettre d'accord entre
sorbonne machin alors qu'elle règle de
l'unanimité sur les sujets fondamentaux
et je vous renvoie la balle de même
manière
donc il faut en sortir pour en sortir
moi je ne vois qu'une solution c'est que
oui il va falloir que les sociétés
européennes elles-mêmes bouge parce
qu'il n'est pas vrai que les allemands
sont homogènes que les français c'est
homogène des désaccords il ya des
clivages sociaux des clubs champions au
sein même des chalets y voyez
aujourd'hui tous ceux sur le sujet
démocratiques sociales écologiques
veulent avancer alors emmanuel macron a
continué un petit peu sur sa lancée
puisqu'il a été mardi soir à epinal pour
lancer ce qu'on appelle des
consultations citoyennes qui leur a
réussi pour le coup a arraché en fait
aux vingt-sept puisque les 27 élèves ont
participé à ces consultations
l'idée donc d'aller aux deux jours des
citoyens européens dé faire débattre sur
l'europe et donc dans un exercice un peu
inédit en stand-up donc il a répondu aux
questions de 450 jeunes femmes jean
després présent en fait à epinal pardon
donc un exercice qui aura duré près de
deux heures
parfois un peu un peu l'eau clémentine
forissier vous y étiez vous êtes là ce
matin vous avez fait la route de nuit
pour être parmi nous qu'est ce que vous
avez retenu de cet exercice est ce que
c'était le lancement d'une campagne un
peu à la mode en marche
ce qui est certain c'est que la mise en
scène faisait penser à certaines à
certaines étapes de la grande marche
mais il y avait comme ça des personnes
au centre entouré de deux publics et une
interaction relativement fort passé
rappelle qu obama dans l'exercice annuel
un peu obama il n'y avait pas beaucoup
de fils train entre le président et les
gens là où les lois de la guerre ici pas
de modérateur il était seul avec un
micro il interrogeait les gens les uns
après les autres en fonction des mains
qui se levait donc dans ce sens là
c'était c'était vraiment intéressant
cette espèce de rapport de proximité et
tout après le problème dans ce genre de
situation c'est que là on assister à
deux heures de questions réponses un peu
de technique en fait presque un peu pour
initier et pourtant je pense qu'il ya
une assez grande honnêteté dans
l'organisation et de filtrage des
questions était pas prévu à l'avancé
mais je pense qu'à une certaine forme de
les gens qui viennent à ce genre de
choses et qui ose poser des questions ne
sont pas posées
voilà sont plutôt des convaincus ou des
gens qui ont un certain une certaine
qu'un certain niveau de réflexion de
connaissances sur ces sujets et les
questions presque plus naïve mais
finalement fondamental que des gens se
posent sur sur l'europe ont pas
forcément été posée est ce qui était
intéressant d'ailleurs de voir c'est que
je pense que le président s'en est
peut-être rendu compte parce qu'à la fin
il a dit non mais j'aimerais bien
répondre à des gens qui sont vraiment
franchement hostile en fait ils ne sont
pas et voilà et et donc il ya eu
quelques mains qui se sont levés et tout
mais c'était trop tard c'était un peu à
la fin il a dit qu'il leur ferait donc
donc on attend effectivement s était le
brouillon peut-être de ces logis de
consultation andré h fabas que
là pour le coup on allait les européens
donc les 27 pays vont en organiser
peut-être vous allez participer à ce
type de consultation est ce que c'est
une bonne manière de remettre le citoyen
au centre du dispositif et du débat sur
l'europe de demain
absolument et je trouve que emmanuel
macron vieira rendu très clair que pour
lui et c'est un peu en différents ce qui
a été dit et par guillaume balas
l'europe ne peut pas être oui ou non il
faut aller dans le détail mais c'est
difficile hein c'est difficile et c'est
plus facile d'avoir des opposants qui
sont vraiment dur là on est à bas on a
les arguments plus facile il ya une
chose qui me gêne un peu d'empathie mais
j'aime beaucoup même dans les
consultations citoyennes
j'espère quand même que c'est pas et
j'ai l'impression que c'est cela pour
l'instant
un bon moyen de payer en marche sa
campagne sur fonds publics européens
parce que elle a deux choses 1 il ya les
consultations citoyennes qui sont
chapeautées par le service du ministère
des affaires étrangères nyan win task
force comme on dit et à côté la grande
marche de en marque
c'est fait exprès c'est à dire que la
grande marche a lieu au moment il ya ces
consultations publiques et donc moi
j'attends toujours de comprendre quelle
va être la possibilité de créer de la
démocratie dans ces consultations
publiques et que ce soit pas simplement
la doxa habituelle qu'ils puissent être
émises et sur un point très important
c'est que en effet si on ne retrouve
dans ces consultations citoyennes que
des gens qui sont convaincus que le
cadre européen c'est important mais que
tous ceux qui aujourd'hui se posent des
questions ils sont hostiles sont à
l'extérieur parce qu'ils ne s'y sentent
pas en fait un invité ça servira à rien
bon bah écoutez on suivra de toute façon
la suite de ces consultations citoyennes
qui vont se tenir jusqu'en octobre et
donc tout ce qui va remonter tout cela
puisqu'il va y avoir aussi un portail
internet un qui va ouvrir sera présenté
aux chefs d'état et de gouvernement lors
du conseil européen de décembre
c'est l'heure du checkpoint préparé par
nos amis de la ftf
cette semaine xavier lambert s'est posé
sur un débat qui nous anime depuis déjà
pas mal de temps donc il ya le breakbeat
mais tout le monde se dit tiens est ce
qu'il serait possible de pratiquer un
deuxième référendum pour éviter la
sortie est bas et xavier lambert a été
vérifié tout cela le checkpoint s'est
tout de suite
un second référendum sur le bauxite
c'est ce que réclame une grande campagne
lancée en avril 2018 par best of britain
de plus en plus de voix britanniques
remettent en cause les conséquences du
premier vote
l'ortho l'afp john key auteur de
l'article 50 qui organise le point site
affirme man je pense qu'il ya maintenant
au moins 30% de chances qu'on organise
un nouveau référendum alors divorce
inéluctable ou les britanniques peuvent
ils encore et calmes et un ex ipsum
bauxite
d'abord rappelons ce qu'est locaux
excite le mot est la contraction de 8
yens et eksi il désigne le départ
volontaire de l'union européenne du
royaume uni il a été approuvé par
référendum le 23 juin 2016 par 52% des
voix contre 48
mais aujourd'hui les britanniques ne
seraient plus que 42 % à approuver ce
break site
comment expliquer ce revirement tout
d'abord il y à de l'huile 50 milliards
pour le royaume uni
ensuite les anglais commencent à voir
les conséquences négatives du divorce
pour l'économie l'emploi ou même la
mobilité des citoyens
enfin il ya les révélation du scandale
cambridge analytique à cette société à
utiliser illégalement les données
privées de millions d'utilisateurs
facebook pour influencer le vote sans
cela il n'y aurait pas eu de pré site
affirme d'anciennes employées
certains politiciens comme l'ancien
premier ministre tony blair estime que
les zambiens ont été induits en erreur
il plaide donc pour un nouveau vote sur
l'accord
techniquement lortholary john kerr a
raison selon l'article 50 le royaume uni
peut faire marche arrière jusqu'à mars
tant qu'il n'a pas signé l'accord
définitif avec les 27 pays membres de
l'union
mais politiquement les observateurs
notent sont unanimes n'y a quasiment
aucune chance qu'un second référendum
soit organisé
theresa may a indiqué clairement dès
qu'elle est devenue première ministre
que son gouvernement respecterait le
résultat du référendum
c'est grâce à la victoire du livre
qu'elle a pris la tête du parti
conservateur puis du pays et même dans
l'opposition le leader travailliste a
fait savoir qu'il ne s'opposerait pas à
la sortie
donc quand l'ordre l'afp john kerr dit
qu'il y à 30% de chances qu'on organise
un nouveau référendum
c'est contestable andreas fab alors un
break back n'est pas possible c'est même
pas souhaitable
je pense c'est possible mais les
clivages politiques en grande bretagne
qui ont fait revivre de cette idée du
bric sites sont les vieux clivages en
france avec les dernières votes de la
présidentielle on a vu des nouvelles
clivages et donc il sera dépendant du
fait six ans brann total il y aura un
nouveau débat comme il ya en france est
pour l'instant j'ai des doutes en tout
cas c'est la démonstration quelque chose
c'est qu'il n'y a pas d'issue
nationaliste à la crise européenne c'est
à dire que tout ce qu'ils disent et
agitent la menace de la sortie de la
france de l'union européenne a comme
étant une solution aux problèmes de la
france
à mon avis font une erreur magistrale au
lieu de parler de quelle europe on veut
en france c'est toujours pareil c'est un
débat théologique c'est pour ou contre
europe alors que la question allait
derrière clémentine forissier vous en a
déjà fait revoter des européens à
plusieurs reprises parce qu'ils avaient
mal voté je pense que c'est c'est une
erreur mais ce serait une erreur
terrible de penser qu'on peut faire
revoter les britanniques
après c'est une décision qui leur
appartient et qui peut être ensuite
validés par les européens mais c'est
quoi ce serait assez mortifère en fait
ils ont fait un choix
quand même en conscience il ya une
campagne c'est un référendum qui a été
annoncée de longue date c'est il ya eu
un vote je pense qu'il faut le respect
ça ça serait à l'image de ce qui s'est
passé en france en 2005
bon merci en tout cas de nous avoir
éclairé sur ce qui s'est passé donc
depuis un an au niveau européen et donc
les réformes voulues par emmanuel macron
se retrouve dans un an pour débattre on
sera en pleine élection en pleine
campagne
merci à tous de nous avoir suivi la
semaine prochaine vous retrouverez ahmed
tazir depuis bruxelles très belle
semaine à tous ciao
[Musique]